[Musique]
et
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip nous
sommes à l'espace richaud à versailles
en compagnie du commissaire de
l'exposition molière la fabrique d'une
gloire nationale
nous accueillons donc martial poirson
martial bonjour ou jours merci nous
accorder du temps pour la deuxième fois
on s'était rencontrés lors de votre
exposition et livre les vous en souvenez
les amazones de la révolution je m'en
souviens très bien voilà donc
aujourd'hui on va parler de molière vous
êtes donc professeur universitaire
appareils 8 quel est votre discipline 1
je suis en histoire culturelle histoire
culturelle et vous êtes aussi auteur
scénariste et commissaire d'exposition
encore une fois voilà ici
l'exposition dure jusqu'au 17 avril on a
encore pas mal de temps devant nous pour
aller la voir et d'admirer en attendant
on va un petit peu en parler je me suis
mise 10 secondes à votre place monsieur
poirson comment aborder un tel travail
aussi ya 400 ans parce qu'on fait les
quatre cents ans de l'anniversaire de la
naissance de notre ami molière bien sûr
522 2022 15 janvier tout à fait car
comment on fait pour s'attaquer à une
telle oeuvre un tel travail et un tel
homme alors oui c'était effectivement un
lourd fardeau on peut dire même s'il a
été extrêmement stimulant et très
motivant à bien des égards puisqu'on est
quand même face à un auteur qui est le
seul auteur de langue française avec
proust à avoir deux éditions pléiade une
biographie de référence des ouvrages
très source et et quatre siècles de
légende on pourrait le dire puisque ne
sachant pas grand chose de la vie de
molière qui restaient relativement
secrète puisque il n'a laissé aucun
manuscrit de ses oeuvres aucune
correspondance privée aucun document
autre que son immense oeuvre de théâtre
plus d'une trentaine de pièces donc dans
les vide laissé par l'histoire se sont
massés au fil des siècles des légendes
qui commence déjà avec le début de sa
vie à onze compte que sa vocation
théâtrale lamy en rupture de lien
familial avec son père que il a dû
renoncer à une carrière de bons
bourgeois de la vie puisqu'il venait
d'une famille d'une riche famille
parisienne de marchands tapissier pour
embrasser une carrière de l'om tout ça
est en fait relativement faux puisque le
père de molière en particulier a soutenu
cet engagement et a même payé ses dettes
au moment de la première faillite de son
théâtre et cette légende se poursuit
jusqu'à sa mort puisque on le dit mort
sur scène et jeté dans la fosse commune
du fait de l'interdiction de l'église
sur la profession des comédiens c'est
également faux l'histoire est moins
belle et en même temps elle est aussi
beaucoup plus riche puisqu'elle permet
de découvrir un homme qui a été quand
même le fondateur de la comédie moderne
à la fois par l'audace dans le
traitement des sujets c'est toute la
société française qui convoquait sur
scène par molière qui passe si je puis
dire c'est bien joli cadeau facile mais
bon il s'en prend à toutes les couches
de la société alors il s'en prend et en
même temps avec une grande bienveillance
et à dire que le rire de molière est
toujours un rire de connivence est
toujours un reer respectueux finalement
des sujets qui en sont la cible y
compris les personnages les plus
négatifs quand même les choses
clairement à disant clairement les
choses en particulier
contestant l'autorité des pères de
famille qui sous lens et dans quel film
dans quel film dans quelle pièce pas y
en a beaucoup mais évidemment la plus
connue c'est probablement la var un père
qui est tellement avare qu'ils en
arrivent à prêter sur gages à des taux
usuraires à son propre fils pour pouvoir
compte revenir à son mariage mais on
pense aussi à l'école des femmes c'est
un non sens explique que pour avoir une
épouse digne de ce nom il faut la
prendre au berceau d'une certaine façon
l'enfermer dans un couvent et puis
ensuite pouvoir donc l'accaparer on est
très très loin de la culture du
consentement on est tous évidemment
faire des enfants et puis c'est à dire
en fait des descendants des héritiers
mâles de préférence donc évidemment
toutes ces figures d'autorité qui font
partie de ce qu'on a dénoncé aujourd'hui
comme le patriarcat sont déjà la cible
de la critique de molière et en même
temps ces personnages restent aussi des
personnages présentés dans leurs
défaillances dans leurs faiblesses
darragon on a presque eu mal pour lui en
fait il est tellement à la traîne voilà
cette névrose de l'argent à la pta
malade c'est un malade on est là tous
les personnages voilà aussi et tutoie
alors donc si si le fait qu'il ait
changé de statut social
elle a quand même changé de statut
social puisque de il aurait dû ils
étaient destinés à cette charge ne
valait du roi et il a choisi
saltimbanques mais c'est ça qui paraît
incroyable sais c'est que ce soit très
très très encouragé par son père donc
c'était encore quand même une profession
très valeureuse et finalement
saltimbanques alors non c'était pas
vraiment non non on peut pas dire que
son père ait favorisé cette vocation est
en tout cas il n'a il ne l'a ni
interdite ni empêché et il l'a même
d'une certaine façon cautionner en
payant aimons les dettes de la troupe de
molière en 1665 mai et saltimbanques
c'est pas vrai non plus en fait le
molière reste malgré tout quelques uns
très entouré même au début un dès le
début de ces années province à partir de
1645 et pour 13 ans il va sillonner la
province mais il va bénéficier de
l'appui des plus grands de ce monde en
réalité il va plutôt aller dans les
relais et châteaux que véritable ring
dans les paysages
quand il va sur les places de l'âge
c'est sous la sous la protection en fait
de riches mécènes je comprends mais
alors je continue le père n'avait pas un
don de divination peut pas savoir qu'ils
allaient réussir de la sorte et être
carrément l'homme de docu de
communication de louis xiv mais c'est la
chose c'est tout le paradoxe de la chose
a été après avoir refusé cette charge de
vallet tapissier de loi qu'il a cédé à
son frère qu'il a repris après la mort 2
malgré tout il est revenu à la cour en
grande pompe si on peut dire comme
responsable comme maître des cérémonies
les divertissements du roi
tout à fait
l'organisateur de grandes fêtes royales
pas tout seul évidemment il écrit depuis
la coopération de très grands
compositeurs comme lully de très grands
maîtres de ballet de très grands
danseurs mais néanmoins il a cette
intelligence du spectacle total il a
cette audace d'inventer quand même pour
son roi un genre la comédie ballet qui
deviendra ensuite l'opéra voire beaucoup
plus proche de nous la comédie musicale
en fait une forme qui mélange la danse
le chant la zik et le récitatif est qui
qui va comme le dit molière lui-même
coudre ensemble en fait tous ces
éléments du spectacle c'est à dire que
la musique n'est pas simplement
ornementale n'est pas destinée
simplement à des divertissements un
petit peu à la marge mais elle fait
partie intégrante de l'oeuvre elle fait
avancer l'intrigué elle fait comprendre
les personnages et donc elle est
vraiment constitutifs de la pièce
d'accord c'est une invention majeure qui
en fait l'ancêtre de du spectacle total
auxquels nos auteurs contemporains
essaye de ceux de s'adonner fois avec
moins de succès d'ailleurs que kader il
y avait vraiment ce génie du plateau wes
comprend alors donc le mieux c'est
d'aller voir cette exposition qui est
extrêmement riche et qui est qui est
extrêmement documenté il ya des pièces
uniques d'ailleurs qui ne doivent pas
être exposés trop longtemps de par leurs
vieilleries
leur dimension patrimoniale merci
patrimoine c'est le perde on est bien
toujours même sujet voilà donc soit on
va voir l'expo soit on lit ce livre que
vous avez édité chez seuil en
collaboration avec la ville de
versailles ou fait les deux qu'ils aient
pas pris mal donc mots liés à la
fabrique d'une gloire nationale c'est
c'est le pendant l'exposition oui tout à
fait alors c'est à la fois le catalogue
dans la mesure où on reprend les grands
thèmes de l'exposition c'est à dire la
représentation de quatre siècles de mots
lyrisme dont la légende s'est institué
s'est transformé au gré des
récupérations politiques dont il a fait
l'objet aussi bien par la monarchie au
moment de la restauration que par la
troisième république qui en a fait
vraiment le l'auteur républicain par
excellence le bréviaire républicain tel
qu'on doit l'enseigné à l'école mais
également la présence de molière dans le
monde luis amado dans ce rapport à la
passe qu'il a été évidemment traduit il
est encore joué dans le monde entier il
a un rayonnement hallucinant à celle
hauteur de la crise le plus lu le plus
traduit et le plus représenté dans le
monde jusqu'à nos jours elle construit
dans les anciennes colonies françaises
où il est pourtant arrivé je dirais
comme un produit d'importation imposé
par par le colon et où il est resté
finalement aussi qu'à un élément
d'émancipation ce qui est très
intéressant aussi bien sûr qu'ils aient
rachid my rachid maraï est un
dessinateur absolument génial selon moi
qui a un trait d'une finesse extrême qui
est par son très satirique en fait qui à
la fois dessinateur de bande dessinée
mais aussi caricaturiste de presse et
qui me semblait vraiment le le
l'excellent des tractations voilà pour
ce fameux roman graphique qui est paru
chez dunod dont vous êtes on peut pas
dire qu auteur vous avez écrit et réagit
mal à dessiner voilà ce roman graphique
il a ce site génial c'est qui reprend la
vie de molière dans son entier jusqu'à
sa mort finalement il est alors la fosse
commune et staff on découvrira tout ça
et
je pense que c'est aussi la force du
dessin des dialogues extrêmement vivant
on plonge vraiment dans cette époque
dans la vie et on se rend compte que ce
ce mot lien il un comment dire un rôle
très très faim ou 14 c'était son mécène
ils sont très proches tous les deux et
on peut dire que c'est son homme de
communication
il est comme le 14 et parrain de son
troisième enfant oui alors il ya une
relation de connivence une communauté
d'idées et de pensées puisqu'à cette
époque là louis xiv et le jeune roi de
danse de chant et d'amour 1 on n'est pas
encore dans la phase vraiment dur du
règne
molière à une quinzaine d'années de plus
que louis xiv et molière mort vraiment
dans la première phase du règne de louis
xiv 73 tirs au moment où versailles
n'est pas encore construit on est dans
les balbutiements ce qu'on montre dans
le roman d'un renvoi versailles en
construction ce qui est également le
moment où le roi reste surtout animée
par les plaisirs de la chasse aux dalles
de la danse et du chant c'est un
excellent danseur oui si les musiciens
bien contente danser sur les rôles si
oui il a quelques rôles alors à l'époque
de molière un peu moins mais en tout cas
ils participent activement il plus qu'un
mécène en fait il est aussi une forme de
directeur artistique d'une certaine
façon du projet est bien tous les deux
voilà alors il ya une connivence qui ne
va pas jusqu'à l'amitié on peut pas être
l'ami d'un roi est sûre quand on est
comédien donc ce mythe de molière ami du
roi
retrouve dans l'exposition avec cette
toile magnifique du déjeuner de molière
à la table du roi qui est une pure
fiction politique un événement on ne
déjeune pas à la table du roi surtout
quand on est rare à l'époque compte tenu
du protocole de cours mais en tout cas
voilà il ya une communauté de vues et
d'idées et il ya surtout un échange de
bons procédés puisque molière offre à
louis xiv
une sorte de reconnaissance symbolique
par les arts est ce qu'on peut dire je
vous coupe la parole très très très très
froidement il avait moins sciemment car
le temps passe est ce qu'on peut dire
que c'était un surhomme pourrait arriver
à faire tout ce qu'il faisait ce maudit
ac milan il endosse tous les rôles du
théâtre entre l'homme de troupes le
directeur le scénariste etc il avait
sans doute une énergie exceptionnelle
et là encore il ya une légende qui
raconte que molière a été malade pendant
des années puis cela rassure c'est
probablement pas en tout cas la
biographie de référence
il avait 51 ans qui à l'époque n'est pas
si jeune
alors aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il est de bon ton j'exerçais
pas c'est pas la bonne expression mais
pour un scénariste d'avoir monté son
mollet il faut avoir fait son tartuffe
son havas et c'est toujours d'actualité
ça oui je pense que molière est et on le
voit bien dans cette année molière avec
notamment la saison molière 2022 la
comédie française mais voilà les prêts
de 22 pièces de ou inspirées par molière
très belle préface d denis podalydès
absolument
s'honore d'avoir sa présence dans le
livre effectivement je crois
qu'aujourd'hui molière a été tellement
monté fait tellement partie de
l'imaginaire de tous les français par
l'école par les théâtres publics par les
théâtres privés également un des rares
auteurs de répertoire qui à la fois
présent sur les scènes publiques et sur
les scènes privées ce qui est assez
intéressant aussi que effectivement
chaque comédien se doit d'avoir monté
son molière et d'une façon qui est tout
à fait différente de celle des siècles
passés puisque pendant longtemps on
essayait de monter molière à la manière
dont on imaginait qu'il avait été
monté en son temps pendant tout le
xviiie siècle on se réclame d'une
tradition de jeu qui probablement a
évolué on laisse aujourd'hui au
contraire l'idée c'est de créer
l'événement en proposant une relecture
nouvelle une interprétation inédite en
nous à les mettre encore en avant
quelque chose qui n'aurait pas été vu
voilà de faire résonner avec les
problématiques de notre temps est ce que
molière et féministe est-ce que molière
critique la domination sociale bien sûr
cette question l'internaute est crucial
nous allons nous séparer martial poirson
un gros merci c'est passionnant c'est un
sujet sans fin il n'est plus un
inépuisable on est d'accord voilà donc
j'encourage tout le monde à aller voir
l'exposition tant que c'est encore
possible et puis de lire ces deux livres
qui nous apprennent beaucoup de choses
l'exo formidable voilà merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi et à très bientôt pour
un nouveau vip
mais